this is a production of Cornell
University
what I am going to try to do is
basically split today into two different
presentations I do want to talk about a
resiliency project that Trevor and I are
working on and I'll get into that here
shortly because we're wrapping up our
research i'm actually he and i are in
process of doing final report for that
and then i am going to talk a little bit
about AG education because what
intrigued me when when I talked to Don
originally is probably trying to fit how
myself as an educator ends up in or
feels comfortable in the horticulture
section and give you a little better
feel for why I think that's a pretty
solid fit and hopefully going forward we
can continue to develop that so to state
it'll be about half and half if all goes
well Trevor will have to wave at me if
I'm going too slow on the research
project so the first one is is the
report from a resiliency growth project
that were just wrapping up we probably
really get kicked off in january of this
year folks involved in that trevor is a
graduate student and myself is principal
investigator we do have Betsy bin who's
based in Geneva also member the
horticulture field that's co-pi on it
dr. nancy wells is a human ecology and
is working with trevor as his primary
chair and has been involved mark smith's
been very involved in our initial
establishment and thinking about the the
research keith Tidball from eden has
also been a collaborator throughout
because we've been using his resource
base and we're actually hitting topics
that are very near and dear to eden as
it comes up in our discussion Caroline
Quentin was an outstanding undergraduate
of mine who I didn't know until we got
going is absolutely talented in coding
interview texts so she took right off
with that and was a great deal of help
so I have to give a shout out to her as
well it's funded by empire state
development I give credit to Betsy is
the one that kind of flagged this at me
hey this is a project that's getting
ready to move down the pike do you want
to get involved with it it's its primary
primary emphasis to get into that is
basically stemming from a whole series
of pretty
severe storms that we've had starting
with Hurricane Irene including hurricane
sandy and Lee and then we had early
spring and really late frost in 2012 we
had unusual flooding and Penn Yan that
they didn't see coming because it was it
was basically not something they never
really planned on or experienced before
and then we had while we're in the
middle of this we had the buffalo severe
severe snow fall event in 2014 that was
the impetus it was back in Irene and Lee
was the original driving force for the
funding from the Empire development
agents our group to do a little bit of
studying on the idea of resiliency
within our agricultural sector what do
we need to do and what are we where we
currently at in terms of resiliency in
that particular arena specific weather
impacts that we start looking at half of
Orange County's cultivated land was
damaged in Irene crop losses just an
ulcer colony where about five million we
didn't have numbers but from the
Schoharie action report the the farms
are devastated a lot of animals were
lost basically the entire infrastructure
was underwater we got a friend of mine
whose house was under 14 feet of water
in schoharie Valley they had a lot of
issue with fall crop damages that the
crops were there but they were so silted
in they had to rethink how to harvest
and could they harvest it was it was
really pushing them beyond the realm of
anything they'd experienced in severe
weather and trying to react to that and
bounce back potential impact I had Jim
held from empire development pull some
numbers if we totally wiped out and this
is specific to the regions that we use
for focus groups I'll show the next
slide so these numbers are very very
localized to specific counties that we
were working with pulled out basically
we're looking at about a billion dollars
in sales just of agricultural sales from
the group of counties that we were
working with in our focus groups so in
the end we're just in a few counties
that we're talking about it was about
seven billion dollars generated that
potentially could be lost that's not
actual losses that's just potential if
we had a total washout like schoharie
Valley
so it's just trying to get an idea of
because some of the discussion is well
why are we even considering this is this
that big a deal well from an economic
standpoint in those communities it's a
really big deal plus we included some
job jobs in those particular areas and
earnings from those particular jobs but
the sales are really what kind of drive
the point home so that's potential
impact if we totally wiped out the
sections we were talking about the focus
group regions so this slide attaches
directly to the colored counties they
are totals just of the colored counties
I I just did it had Jim run that data so
we can compare within the different
focus groups I wanted to see if there
was any huge difference from the western
New York group to the ultra green
Columbia County group and we really
didn't find they were very similar
across those economic impacts which is
interesting given the diversity of our
New York State this slide we in bounced
back to but this is the focus group that
we started working with when I get into
the actual methodology will refer back
to that slide because each color code is
a group that we pulled together for
focus groups to talk to producers I get
there in just a minute the overall goals
of the project literally had we had
three particular areas of interest we're
trying to outline economic impacts and
define where producers were in terms of
extreme weather it was always it was a
good diverse discussion to have we've
talked the north country folks they're
already familiar with snow snow wasn't a
huge issue they automatically reverted
back to the ice storm which was way
outside of our school but there are
still stars in there that that's what
they needed to talk about it was the one
time where they were totally caught off
guard and they learned quite a bit from
being out of power for extended period
of time we started talking to scary and
scarier obviously was the the severe
flooding we started talking to Buffalo
region they were they weren't quite as
concerned they got through the snow
event where there was some issue other
issues that they had they were really
where the frost frost event started to
become very crisp in their minds when
they started talking about trying to
figure out how to recover and plan a
in that extreme weather case we also are
looking at strengths and weaknesses of
emergency response systems is the
commute the communication system that we
already have in place effective or not
effective as seen from the producers as
well as our non producer group so we had
two different groups that I'll show in
our methods courses or methods
discussion and then really trying to
assess farmers concern regarding severe
weather events a disaster planning are
they doing anything for planning are
they worried about severe weather how
does this topic impact them and are they
considering that as we move forward so
those three goals with over overarching
perspective of the project had six
different research questions which will
pop up again that really we tried to
dress those specific goals on preventive
steps that were already in place
additional privet what didn't we have in
terms of preventive steps for the event
that they were focusing on what factors
impacted decisions we had one farmer
that was adding it wasn't weather
related but he was now investing 20,000
for deer fence because he'd made a
decision that it was finally time to
invest that money he was losing too much
from deer impact which wasn't
weather-related specifically hello in
the last couple winters we start talking
about deer pressure because of the heavy
snow load the deer pressure was directed
towards them because it was food source
so we factors then we ended up with
factors impacting those responses the
note basically we've got along with the
producers we're also looking at
extension educators we're looking at
researchers and we're looking at state
agencies agata markets Red Cross Dec
what were their interests and what were
their thoughts compared to the producers
so we've got those two non producer
groups and producer groups that were a
subset and also part of our focus group
that I'll get through in just a second
what new capacity is needed to mitigate
so what do we have to add to this and do
we have a capacity already in our land
grant system extension the research to
respond to weather-related crises or are
there areas that we need to develop so
we're really looking for where
are we at what can we move forward to
was very exploratory in nature a last
one how do we evaluate our response to
disaster and assess the strength of
networks used to coordinate efforts that
one was a true it was a great idea to
have that on the list we got very little
feedback from that in our focus groups
that one basically went unanswered
because we couldn't rather the data was
just not developed in the way we
presented our interview formats methods
really we've got six regions identified
which was the colored map that I showed
a little earlier we've got producers in
each of those areas the producers were
invited by any means we could I think
Trevor and I both thought we were going
to be in it made good sense we were
providing them a stipend to pay for
their time we're providing them lunch
and we're trying to do it off harvest
times and we still struggled in some
case some counties are really really
engaged but we weren't getting the
participation that we wanted we worked
farther out into our network of
extension and Farm Bureau to populate
the focus groups we did get very
interested participants but we were a
little thinner than we thought in total
numbers and we really tried to address
that as we move forward and and we're
consistently afforded in our efforts to
double the size of our focus groups but
we're basically at six or eight
participants per focus group which
worked well for in-depth discussion I
would have liked to had a second focus
group in each region and we were unable
to do that beyond the producers we did
pull in a state agency all of groups
listed came together in Albany for a
focus group to get their perspective we
pulled in two different extension
educators groups one of the western part
of the state one in hudson valley as
well as some local participants in the
focus groups that we had in our producer
sections we did have one it syracuse
with FSA representatives as one because
they're a direct link up to the federal
level tried to have some other producers
coming on that one and it ended up being
just the FSA group very intriguing
discussion points when we started
talking from FSA and their connection to
the feds in the states
compared to our other ones script and
the questions were developed one for
producers we slightly modified it for
non producers both were approaching the
six research questions and developing
directly from those all meetings were
actually recorded and transcribed and we
used macs QD a software for coding
analysis but our analysis took two
different paths we've got one that's
really using the coding system using
Mac's kewda we've got some results based
on that we then actually took a little
more of a s it was a high-energy
approach where Trevor and I basically
went back through our transcripts as we
were coding and then started to break
out into charts the differences across
all those research groups trying to get
a little deeper than just the coding
because we were finding the coding was
giving us some raw results we needed to
find some actual specifics down
underneath so we did another layer that
we'll see here shortly when we start
talking about results we break out the
coating the nice thing is it kind of
hits you with a broad spectrum
discussion points of what we found right
away right off the bat 137 citations for
resource demand and influence the
producers this is from the producers
really needed the thing they were
looking for is continued development of
opportunities for developed continued
resource development and how do we
connect to those resources and it was
across the spectrum because we did have
each focus group had different target
points one was the north country or they
were talking ice and transportation to
foodstuffs if the roads are shut down
how are we going to get through our
product to the market and how do we get
food up into the region if we don't have
that food available where we start
talking in western New York they weren't
quite as worried about that they were
much more worried about simply clearing
the snow out of the way and then
worrying about water we had some water
discussions out that way so it really
was very much independent of their focus
groups which you would mix which makes
intuitive sense but they all did focus
for 137 references on resources the
other one that was very similar in
height as emergency communication and
that didn't distinguish positive and
negative it just noted in the coding
that it was related to emergency
communique
the good news of this discussion was
they were very happy with the emergency
communication system as a general feel
from the state level down to the county
level that commits we were were at first
the one of the driving forces for this
study is was there a connection were the
producers feeling well connected to the
emergency systems when something happens
and across all the focus groups they
were actually quite positive with their
County systems and their connections to
Agra markets Agra markets has I mean
it's one woman is basically runs that
whole emergency management system they
all knew her and she's very well
connected to all the counties it was
very encouraging to hear that at the
same time we'd have a discussion on the
negative side the local folks weren't
talking to the counties so the villages
were disconnected with the counties so
in some cases there was a breakdown of
communication there there were some
counties that had some variability of
breakdown from the pru sure side to the
emergency response side there was
variability in there but across the
board they were very positive they also
saw extension I think it'll show up in
another one extension soil and water and
and their emergency response teams were
very active in making sure that the AG
community was brought into the fold when
a disaster hit the Extension Service was
rough was resource site in 62 times in
our discussion as well that was part of
a discussion to see how they were
fitting into the county level if you're
familiar with the extension system it is
the associate associations some counties
have very limited associations based on
budgetary constraints and some and some
historical resource points and there we
saw that variation but overall across
the focus groups who are working with
their very positive about their
extension systems if the extension
educators weren't there the soil and
water folks picked that up the recovery
issues weren't quite as strong as the as
the top three but we're still they were
that was basically talking about okay
well we're really worried about is the
aftermath how do we pick up the pieces
and keep moving forward this is where
crop insurance starts popping up as a
reference point which will we'll see in
a specific site we were talking about
popular resources into recovery do we
have generators for a long enough period
of time do we have the planning in place
that we can actually get to the
resources and establish recovery so
those are just the the key results from
the coding breakout but as I talk Trevor
and I got talking and wanted to go a
little more in depth to try to connect
those core really broad stroke pieces to
some inches specific details further
analysis just some examples that pop up
under resources the big one that
hammered basically across all counties
we've already if you're if you've
listened to NPR it's one of governor
Governor Cuomo's points already internet
access and cell phone coverage is very
weak in some of our areas we get
producers where it's not available
you've been on a good day the loan in
the disaster now a lot of the
communication systems are starting to
expect us to have cell phones and
internet connection well we've got parts
in our counties that don't have that
even on a good day it's extremely slow
that's becoming an issue that was very
vocalized there like we need to fix that
first and then we can build up from
there North Country was talking about
generators they basically already solved
that problem but it was it seemed to be
their key point that was in the back of
their minds the other operations i
mentioned transportation and
infrastructure we're really they said
yeah that's fine for the dairies but the
non dairies were really more worried
more about getting produce or product
out from their farms or into the
community to make sure the communities
had resources just to not stress because
of lack of food and basic supplies
emergency communication related topics
as i mentioned the counting state were
really sets seen as satisfactory the
local level had an awful lot of
variability depending on whether they
thought to eat rate read their emails
and were they engaged in the practices
for emergency response the federal level
was i was hoping to have better
connection to the federal level and even
the state level they didn't have a good
clear vision of the connection back up
to FEMA and whenever you talked about
FEMA that that fizzled out really really
fast there was not as much discussion
about that federal connection even from
the state level as I expected the state
is very organized and has a lot of plans
in place the federal level when we
connect up to that fed level it
go a lot of it goes through FSA and the
FSA discussion was there's some internal
communication issues so the federal
level we've got more work to do that one
basically didn't have a data we wanted
it to pull together oh yes thank you FSA
is Farm Service Agency very involved in
providing resources from the federal
level both to farms that meet specific
qualifications they are also the Farm
Service Agency is the primary agency
that that will do a decide on a federal
declaration of disaster it funnels
through their agency for whatever reason
when the state starts looking at the
point where it's so bad that they've got
to go at the federal level for disaster
which opens up federal aid back to the
state so that farm service agency is a
conduit for that but it's primarily seen
as a lending resource for farmers that
meet those requirements they set for
federal aid thank you done for
clarifying that and as I talked about it
at the Extension Service and so on water
districts are very involved in each of
the regions it's kind of what we
expected that but there was some
discussion of how broadly that's going
to show up and both of them were very
strongly reported the other thing I'm
going to do my watch my time I truncated
these these are splitting the other
directions so we've got a producer
response on the lesson on producers on
the right these are related to each
number is one of the six research
questions that we focused on effective
preventive steps element that popped up
here and didn't show up on the coating
the use of pictures and internet on
phones and internet to send information
right away Eden uses this already they
start doing what's the term for trevor's
we're doing
crowdsourcing they're doing
crowdsourcing to map their data as the
event hits the educators are sending in
information off their phones right away
so in a very short period of time in the
middle of the crisis they can start to
populate where the issues are happening
it's especially when we start talking to
Eden about we had a hail event in Homer
that I don't think anybody else in
cortland Tompkins County had I've got 10
or 15 houses that are replacing their
entire siding and roofing through
insurance because they had hail damage
in this 15 10 acre plot I don't know is
like when I talk to the growers that
they didn't see any damage because it
was mostly Hey but those types of things
are being identified through this use of
crowdsourcing that was one effective
preventive step additional preventive
step economic marketing analysis some
room for improved ideas and some tools
so that they can start to identify how
we make a change what do we do for as
part of the plan what's the cost if we
don't choose to do that if we say okay I
want to invest in one thing we talked
about was water as a big topic do we not
only flooding but also water attention
should we be paying attention to storing
more of the water that we have so that
we if we're going to carry through times
like our August was really really dry
not all farms or set up for irrigation
and don't have the water resources
should we be leaning that way that was a
discussion that came up in our summit
which I'll get to in a minute so some
more thought process of tools the
producers can use because they're
starting to think about these issues but
non producers really we're also
confident the experiment the
communication they did see some issues
with soil erosion after storm and trying
to improve exposure for New York Eden
New York Eden is the extension disaster
education network based in natural
resources here on campus and they are
starting to they've got really great
resources but there was a discussion of
trying to make sure they're they're
getting their message out more to a
broader population so that it's there
what needs to grow the third and fourth
ones factors impacting economic
decisions again they wanted a little
more some more tools to use for
cost-benefit analysis as they do work on
their plan
a very responsive very response in
davila the responses were very
individualized depending on what focus
group you were working with as a whole
clear communication from connie a state
level i already hit that on the non
producer side the one thing we talked
about was economics to design we were
talking about the Buffalo snowstorm were
a lot of barns that collapsed and just
having some numbers and some tools too
because you can the one situation we
also talked about was a greenhouse an
entire business greenhouse business that
was totally flattened and you can only
reinforce and / build greenhouses so far
because before they become cost
prohibitive have that discussion and to
start to look at some economics they
used to do that back when this was AG
engineering we had all sorts of tables
for some of that type of resource I'm
not we hadn't seen that at the state
level of the agencies they hadn't seen
new data relative to snow loads and
thought that was interesting to to
consider as an option and then one thing
they brought up was once you go through
the flood or you go through the
snowstorm you're better prepared next
time which is totally intuitive but they
brought to at the point of okay when we
start working the producers that have
done this they're a lot more compared
the next time we just have to get their
neighbors to learn you know if
neighboring counties didn't go through
the Schoharie flawed learn from what
they're doing and try to grow before it
hits them personally last two we already
talked about internet and cell phone
coverage for response in terms of new
capacities there was a mention of GPS
locations available which county should
already have but we were unsure of the
uniformity of across the county's areas
for further research one area was and
this was the area for far for local for
future resource really emphasized
small-scale agriculture that was also
nature of the focus groups that we had
our Batavia group was probably the only
one that I can think of that we had
large operators there just by nature we
were in scary scary had a couple to
that's true so we had large operators
and scary and large in Batavia but the
other ones were
Merrilee just self selected to be
smaller operators the larger ones were
pointedly invited but chose not to
participate so it's one of the devices
and issues we have with the focus group
format but they like a little more
resources put into extension which were
already trying to do from Cornell
University doing our active research out
to the extension office's I think that
pathway could be strengthened and that's
one of the points they bring up there
also they brought up FSA does a similar
course thing where they've got data from
their agents and that they didn't
realize Eden was using it and vice versa
it'd be really great if they could just
communicate a little bit and and come so
they had a really strong resource base
I'm trying to make those connections
because the two groups had not actually
sat down and had a discussion about how
each of their crowdsourcing worked and
then one element we also talked about
from the state agency wise what happens
if the cell phone system is down in
Internet's down do we have a mechanism
in place when it gets bad enough where
the cell towers are out and the
Internet's down because the
infrastructure is overflowed so it looks
similar to what happened in Sandy that
hasn't been answered or addressed some
of the cell phone towers now have
generators which will help but that was
one of those that everybody's like oh
yeah okay we don't want to go there so
we need to start having that discussion
of what's the next step to make sure our
infrastructure is stabilized concept map
we also took the overall coding laid out
and tried to come up with a flowchart
just to conceptualize what we're talking
about really the trigger is a severe
weather event the interesting thing we
found is basically all producers agreed
there either a low-end them end of
emergency planning or moderate planning
nobody honestly said they were an
outstanding planning so I left damage in
there instead of high-level planning so
after the event if we go through low
level of plan that's going to cause some
adaptation by force because they weren't
prepared for it something has happened
and they've got to catch back up if they
had a moderate level of plan they're
going to have to show some resiliency so
it's not going to affect them quite as
much that'll trigger down into that
affects all of our producers but also
brings the government levels in the
government meaning
local and county levels we start feeding
in information the resources from the AG
service agencies into the producers and
that producer can start working with the
resources that they have or the
resources that they need to track down
as well as trying to refine the
emergency planning resources are feeding
up into communications resources and
planning as a thought process to realize
that those producers have to engage with
all three of those towards the idea of
bringing the resources in and this is
probably the second iteration maybe
third iteration of the model we keep
keep trying to refine how to best
present the the flow because it's not
exactly linear simply because it's
that's the nature of the seer weather
process there are a couple models that I
could pull in our in my other resource
or the next phase of this and research
I'm doing in my dissertation I've got a
different set of models that probably we
should we compared with this we weren't
trying to do that we're just trying to
explain what happened in the information
we collected we did have a couple
community values just statements that
revered pulled out that really kind of
said what they were thinking from
producers perspective you know in my
community we've got a farming attitude
everybody cares about his neighbor and
that's worth more than anything else
there's no government program that can
replace that they're going to make sure
and and these are farmers basically
saying okay I'm going to be a farmer
we're going to make sure this we're
going to solve the problem one where the
other they aren't actively going out
looking for resources from the community
they like to have that infrastructure
there but they're also in some cases the
first ones length down at the bottom I
think the farmer just as all we have the
ability to deal we're the ones that are
going to clean up at if there's a major
weather event or make the repairs or
replant or rebuild with the help of the
insurance company they'll step in and
make sure the resources are provided I
know one of the growers I talked to you
know worst case the worst case scenario
he takes the tractor down the road opens
the road up because the plows haven't
gotten that far the milk truck can get
through that brings up an interesting
discussion of liability which we started
to discuss the but at the end of the day
they're going to solve the problem and
so that came through and quite regularly
is yes the communication system is
pretty solid but we also feel if we've
got a good
moderate level of planning we can
weather most of the incidents I don't
i'm not sure i think that was also the
opinion of schoharie county until they
got hit with a 500 year flood level that
they weren't expecting and they had to
rethink their Ledet level of preparation
we then as a final piece pulled together
would we have 50 about 50 or 60
individuals in Geneva for a resiliency
summit as part of the grant that was the
next stage where broadens researchers a
different set of educators a couple
producers and key pieces surface here
that we didn't see in our focus groups
the huge the two big ones were water
retention and erosion issues especially
retention should we be paying attention
to keeping the water on site instead of
letting it go down the rivers or do that
as some mitigation for flooding in a
broader perspective soil quality and
stabilization Wade one producer was
adamant that that should have been and
it is important i think we were freezing
it such that that was an understanding
but should we be paying attention to
make sure that this doesn't infringe on
our soil quality economic incentives how
do we get the producers to engage in
emergency planning the smaller guys
don't have the time and don't feel they
have the money the larger operators all
have some degree of emergency planning
built into k foes and their nutrient
plans are they actually implementing the
process a lot of times it'll sit on the
shelf how do we encourage them to
actually think of this as part of the
planning the AG businesses are not
always connected to the County EMS
system emergency management system so
the businesses are quite often are the
agricultural businesses sometimes are
separated out and are not is tightly now
aware we did talk about crop insurance
that popped up quite a bit with
everybody agreed it's an important tool
but it has some flaws in terms of being
designed for Midwest where we struggle
to adapt it overall County Planning was
also seen as strong but there were some
communication gaps next steps from that
we're basically doing a summary report
but from the summit we've actually got
Agra markets connect connected with
Trevor and I and we're working on a next
step they've got they'd like to take
another step forward we haven't
discussed what that was but
he's excited to meet with with me in
November to figure out how we move
forward along with Keith out of Eden
trevor is doing a perception of climate
change produce from the producers so
we're trying to go in that direction I'm
actually taking a dissertation off of
this base grant looking specifically at
at the county level there's a local
emergency planning committee mandated by
the state so every state has one or
every county has one but I'm also
finding in talking to a couple of them
there's an interesting amount of free of
variability in terms of how useful there
that's where the agricultural folks
should have connections to the emergency
response it's not happening in all the
counties so the next step is to figure
out why that's not happening even though
it's mandated by the state in some cases
the connections are not being made in
some counties they're being very well
made and it's not as much of an issue so
those are the three different directions
we're going to go right out of the
report we've also we're going to develop
fat sheets and tease out the data into
some more specific details we can send
back to our extension agents so they've
got a growth point there was a lot of
interest in the summit to just summarize
where this was as a launching point for
there's also money coming through to
soil and water agencies for more
specific water mitigation manure storage
cover mitigation and there was a third
one what have been related to soil that
they're getting ready to roll out as
well so as an exploratory project that
seemed to develop the interest in the
and start to answer some of the missing
information pieces that we couldn't find
in the literature all right quick any
questions on that then I'm going to
switch to my AG education piece so this
is phase one yes
11 that we actually had in the
resiliency summit was there's salt which
is a community generated program in
schoharie county that's totally
community-funded they're actually
establishing resource networks and a
much tighter of understanding of the
resources that are available and the
planning that's necessary to meet that
500 year flood so they've they've been
around for fair enough well yeah three
years totally originally grant funded
and now they're established establishing
the resource and much more careful data
points so everybody in the community has
some access to what happens if this
develops and that was really a model we
had presented at the summit that I think
more counties where there's a high risk
factor could use to just establish they
have a couple people on staff and they
actively work with the community members
to make sure that level of emergency
planning is high because then you can
vary depending on what the producer
needs are and the community needs are
yeah read question any other questions
we can come back to these if you want
I'm going to keep going because I run it
worry about getting running out of time
so that was the research we've been
working on which side project my day job
AG education and sips the I'm associated
with the aggregate agricultural outreach
program you probably not see most of
these folks Katie works off the office
out of the office in the North Country
she's a director of New York Evan
classroom deals with K through 12
educators the AG literacy day where they
read a children's book that's factually
accurate for agriculture to remember how
many thousands of children each year
that's for one of her big projects
yesterday executive secretary currently
julia philosophy we just hired derek
hill Julie's going to minnesota manages
the FFA we've got 6,000 students in and
after AG programs across the state which
i'll show you a map of she manages those
two she's on campus Terry and sherry or
ones in cobleskill and one is in the
north country providing
recruitment specialists and also support
for agricultural education teachers that
community is part of who I am as I
assume the director responsibilities but
that'll be the team that I'm working
with Mikey job is really working in the
AG science realm I've got 23 AG science
advisees that really focus on the soils
crops horticulture and education
perspectives so I just kind of Shepherd
them through as undergraduates and make
sure they're focusing on whatever
perspective they have and and refine
their career choices as we go through
the education minor has about 75 each
each class under class group has about
75 participants continuing to grow a
little bit Brian Duff and I basically
are working with the rest of our faculty
there's education faculty and
developments ocean anthropology that
Shepherd the minor and maintain that the
other key piece the least to me the
exciting part is i teach the art of
teaching it's a large survey course
university-wide to about 300 students a
year every semester we run that and I've
got Trevor's in there now as my graduate
ta along with Emily Dickinson Dietrich
and we've had I think three different
years this is a third year running
graduate teaching opportunities for
horticulture students and it's been
outstanding each one Emily's got an
interest in public gardens and and some
art history background and it's been a
really strong connection grant thompson
last year was outstanding and really has
shown some growth growth as he prepares
for teaching in his professional career
so it's been a great opportunity to
present i also when I saw my other job I
guess it comes up in my next slide two
more slides i also am coordinating the
student teaching and agricultural
education project at ithaca college
cornell used to have AG education
masters degree master's program that's
that dissolved in 2013 due to funding
and political situations but at the same
time the Dean reached out and picked out
picked up if a colleges program
and we've partnered with them and half
of what we do is is actually the whole
thing is really plant and animal based a
good half of what we do in Ag education
is plant-based the other half is going
to be animal science based I spent this
is actually sure of my greenhouse when I
taught in high school we're doing some
irrigation work and also trying to work
on some potting development and I've
also got good alignment with both
extension programs across the state and
the public garden Marcia Shein sheave
Lee and the projects between that and
plantations we have we're stronger
building stronger and stronger
connections across those opportunities I
also teach the extensions Corps
extension outreach an instruction course
that align much better with the public
garden and extension perspective because
it's not specific with high school a few
details about the education piece all
the blue actually all the colors the red
colors are colleges all the other
colleges or other all the other dots
blue and green have some connection to a
high school agricultural program in some
cases their full fully fledged AG
programs with a certified teacher in
some cases they don't have a certified
teacher but they're teaching in
environmental science through a science
teacher or they're teaching aquatics
down on Long Island I've got a couple
marine science programs they're nice
certified AG teachers a certified
biology but all these folks have and
somehow engaged with our agricultural
resource folks that in terms of specific
AG we're talking about 250 teachers with
four positions over right now that I
can't fill so the growth is actually an
upward swing that's where this comes in
supply and demand nationally all the red
states are in shortage for AG teachers
again I'm drawing from animal science
heavily muscled giant from AG science
agricultural science majors to draw them
into the master's program as one
opportunity for the careers to teach at
least I taught for 17 years then I
transition to farm net and I'm
transitioned here it's something that
they at least keep in the back of their
mind I've got one young man that
teaching in high school he went through
education got certified he's and case I
each made a position for him he's
training training people across the
Midwest for whatever they wanted to
pain but they hired him because of his
educational and marketing skills so
there's definitely a shortage across
most parts of the country our pathway is
connecting with Ithaca College we've got
an articulation agreements so there's
there's nine credits actually up to 12
credits that can transfer across the two
institutions will start up the first
mate the first cohort this may i'll
probably have six teachers that are in a
13 month program that will be on campus
for a couple of the classes and then
I'll supervisor student teaching out
into the workforce as well personal
background which is a deeper connection
to the agricultural roots I did Don
mentioned my ostrich I raised ostrich
for 10 years in western New York that's
a different I got a different power
point on that we can talk about that and
the markets basically dissolved so I've
switched to heritage breed hogs this is
one of my American guinea hogs my
daughter the artist snapped that picture
so I were working with American guinea
hogs just as a hobby now did work
professionally as a landscaper in
blacksburg Wiles put myself through
graduate school I actually taught
horticulture and turf and golf course
design for actually 15 years not 17 15
years in western New York along with
forestry and then dotted mentioned my BS
here in Ag education of my masters at
virginia tech questions Wow well first
of all men you for being the first
speaker
come here who has actually finished
figure we had to have some time for
questions because this is kind of off
the beaten track a question actually
warp or Trevor possibly to what degree
the duties of participants in your focus
groups made a tie-in between these
individual extreme weather events and a
broader subject of global climate change
so we were we cut climate change out of
our script we didn't our consider all
about City color came up it wasn't an
article kiss group but it's probably in
around once they have POTUS in fifty
percent just brought it up of their own
volition II because we were we were
actively told to not use the term
climate change based on a punter so it
came up fifty percent of the time
organically as part of our discussion
some questions thank you so much dad
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu